mais d'abord donc ce coup de tonnerre du
côté de Tours métropole son président
Frédéric Augis se vient de démissionner
avec le maire de Tours Emmanuel Denis la
cossigne aujourd'hui un courrier où ils
expliquent conjointement qu'une
refondation est nécessaire et qu'il est
essentiel qu'un exécutif renouvelé
prenne vie sur la base de l'ouverture
une façon de dire qu'il est temps de
trouver une forme de cohabitation
apaisée écouter les précisions
d'Emmanuel Denis
on ne pouvait pas rester finalement dans
ce cette position un peu bancale que
tout le monde trouvait un peu ubuesque
la ville sang doit être au centre de la
métropole donc elle doit retrouver sa
place il va y avoir des déçus des vices
président qui ne seront plus
bah écoutez ça on le verra en tous les
cas ce qui est important c'est de dire
que on est on rentre dans une phase où
on va retourner vers un équilibre plus
cohérent avec les résultats des
élections municipales 2020 ce que l'on
souhaitait après il y a toujours des
perdants et des gagnants en tant que
maire de tour je j'attends comme vous
que on puisse présenter l'ensemble de la
liste du de l'exécutif la semaine
prochaine et c'est à ce moment-là où on
verra les le positionnement d'ici là
voilà on va continuer à travailler pour
caler toutes les choses pour que voilà
on est une belle copie à présenter
vendredi prochain et que l'ensemble du
Conseil puisse s'engager avec le nouvel
exécutif
mission n'est pas un
once le président de Tours métropole
l'ancien président de Tours métropole à
d'ores et déjà annoncé qu'il était
candidat sa propre succession mais il
souhaite également que la ville de Tours
est une place au sein du futur exécutif
la fin d'une guerre des chefs résumé
d'un an et demi de tergiversation avec
Romain Delville
élection du président de la métropole
acte 3 après wilfridge Schwartz
démissionnaire en juillet 2021 c'est au
tour de Frédéric oGIS de donner sa
démission mais pas dans les mêmes
circonstances wilfridge Schwartz était
acculé par des ennuis judiciaires pour
avoir giflé un collaborateur cette fois
Frédéric Augis semble remettre les
choses à plat en ouvrant de nouveau la
porte aux élus de la ville de Tours et
en annonçant illico qu'il se présente à
sa succession une décision saluée par
Thierry Chaillou le maire de ballon-miré
je pense que c'est l'objet de cette
démission c'est de retrouver un
équilibre et une collégialité dans la
gestion de la métropole je pense que
c'est comme ça qu'on arrivera à faire
avancer notre métropole et qu'on fera
des projets pour le bénéfice de nos
habitants selon nos informations la
nouvelle gouvernance pourrait
s'articuler avec quatre nouveaux
entrants parmi l'opposition actuelle
dont trois ont été demandés pour les
seuls élus de Tours Christophe Bouchet
opposant à Tours et observateurs
critique à la métropole en souhaite plus
pour la ville centre j'entends et je
l'accueille avec enthousiasme finalement
que
t'offre Frédéric augix Emmanuel Denis
souhaite
regrouper toutes les sensibilités
j'y mettrai une nuance toutes les
sensibilités tous les équilibres
démocratiques dans le respect de ce côté
tous les habitants de la métropole il y
a trois ans à 3 ans de la fin des
mandats municipaux un nouveau virage est
pris à métropole celui de la
reconstruction et des sujets qui
rassemble tramway et gestion des déchets
en tête les sujets qui fâchent ce sera
pour plus tard la métropole c'est aussi
de la politique et de la stratégie il y
a des élections qui vont arriver pas
tout de suite mais on les prépare
l'avenir se prépare et s'ils veulent se
mettre en ordre de marche et
oGIS Emmanuel Denis pour ne pas laisser
la place à d'autres je pense on peut
penser à Benoît pierre à Christophe
boucher qui n'attend que la chute de
cela pour reprendre du pouvoir c'est
maintenant qu'il faut agir chacun
chacune des 87 conseillers
métropolitains prépare ses armes et ses
éléments de langage pour le vendredi 17
mars jour d'élection du président de la
métropole une formalité pour Frédéric
oGIS
jour surtout d'un nouvel exécutif le
quatrième en trois ans celui tourné vers
la fin du mandat